good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical
data science seminar series it is my
honor to welcome our speaker today dr
andre irimia who is assistant professor
at the usc leonard davis school of
gerontology
at the university of southern california
he completed his bachelor's degree in
computer science and mathematics from
lipscomb university in 2002
followed by a master's degree in
computer science from vanderbilt
university in 2004
and an ms and phd in biophysics from
vanderbilt
in 2007. he's completed postdoctoral
fellowships at uh
in brain mapping and neurophysiology at
uc san diego
as well as in multi-modal neuro imaging
at ucla
and since um uh uh
since that time he's um uh been based
now at uh the
both the ucla and at the university of
southern california
dr ermey is a computational
neuroscientist neurogerontologist
biomedical engineering researcher and
biophysicist
with interest covering a broad range of
topics in neural injury
degeneration plasticity and repair his
research utilizes computational
biological approaches and multimodal
imaging to study how the brain
connectivity alterations caused by
insults to the brain
contributes to connectome reorganization
to cognitive degeneration
and to recovery he's published
extensively on mr physics
anatomic structural theory
bioengineering as well as inverse
localization
and human brain imaging a key component
of this research is trying to understand
the relationship between brain injury
amyloid angiopathy dementia and how
these conditions interact with one
another
this focus includes vascular dimensions
of neural degeneration and cognitive
decline
as well as the interaction between
cardiovascular health and brain atrophy
he's particularly interested in unique
populations with atypical aging profiles
similar to what we are going to hear
about today his work is funded through
grants from the national institutes of
health as well as from the department of
defense
and his lecture today is entitled brain
aging inflammation and cardiovascular
health
insights from an indigenous
pre-industrial society in south america
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube and
if you're watching via youtube
uh thank you so much for joining us
we'd also like to invite our specially
selected
2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants
to submit any questions that they have
for dr irmia via the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of dr eramia's lecture and with that
welcome andre
we are really looking forward to your
lecture
good morning jack thank you very much
for that very kind introduction and
uh thank you for having me here i'd like
to thank you
and the organizers for inviting me to
speak
at this year's innovation lab
and the topic of my talk today
lies at the intersection of brain aging
neuroinflammation vascular disease and
dementia
in industrialized societies like our own
it turns out that dementia and vascular
disease are a major cause of death and
as you can see on this slide
if we tally up the causes of death
worldwide we find that nearly a third of
them
are accounted for by vascular disease
whether cerebral vascular
or cardiovascular disease and
alzheimer's disease
uh and of the top ten uh causes of death
uh that are uh um known
uh ad is the only one which cannot be
prevented or
cured so obviously we have a
uh an important mission to understand
how
alzheimer's disease uh interacts with
with the vascular components of brain
function and
structure uh and there has been a lot of
research
and interest on relating cerebrovascular
disease
to cardiovascular disease and uh
to uh on in understanding how uh these
two facets of uh
brain health are related to cognitive
impairment
and how they can lead to alzheimer's
disease down the road
one interesting aspect about alzheimer's
disease
is that there is an increasing amount of
interest
in the question as to how our modern
lifestyles
might affect dementia risk so we do not
live
the lives that our ancestors did we have
a very
different industrialized society
we most humans live in urbanized
environments
and it's estimated that the percentage
of
individuals living in urban areas will
increase
dramatically throughout the 21st century
and with urbanized environments and
modern lifestyles
come air pollution a sedentary lifestyle
unhealthy diets especially in western
societies
and it is known that these factors
affect cardiovascular health
and perhaps even brain health and
there's been
gathering evidence to suggest this uh
and what prospective uh studies have
found
is that there are significant
associations between
alzheimer's disease hypertension
and obesity and uh it would be very
interesting to know
whether alzheimer's disease is a
byproduct of modern environments which
contain these environmental factors that
are damaging
to health they're damaging to
brain health and the cardiovascular
system
so to answer that question we have to
turn to
populations that live traditional
pre-industrial lifestyles
that are similar to those experienced in
human prehistory now unfortunately there
are very few
uh populations uh that are like that
left in the world today there are very
few uh
groups of people that have not been
affected by
uh the modern uh industrial by the
industrial revolution first of all and
by the
um technological advances that occurred
after that in the past several centuries
there are very few people still left
that live
uh traditional lifestyles that are
similar to those experienced by humans
during
uh prehistory and uh
however uh there is one at least one
such
group that is uh very interesting
uh for especially for that reason and we
have been studying
that group for quite a while
this is the chimane people of the
bolivian amazon
so in the lowland regions of the amazon
as you can see here in this square
highlights
the area of bolivia uh where
the chimane people live uh have
this industry a pre-industrial lifestyle
uh that they have preserved to a
remarkable extent
this is a population of about 16
000 people who practice
a traditional style of agriculture
there are hunter-gatherers and
horticulturalists
uh they live in the bolivian amazon uh
basin
and they have been studied by u.s
researchers for
over 20 years and um i have been part of
this collaboration
for the past five years and i would like
to share with you today
some of the insights that we have gained
from
the chumane regarding
cardiovascular health inflammation and
how these
factors affect uh brain aging and
potentially
the risk for dementia so the chimanei
uh health and lifestyle project got
started
uh over 20 years ago and
its aim is to study the chumane people
of bolivia the chumane
live a subsistence lifestyle they do not
have access to
[Music]
electricity modern or any of the modern
uh the staples of modern society that we
are used to they live in a very remote
and inaccessible region of uh the
bolivian
amazon basin it is they
live in traditional villages
they obtain their food either by hunting
using bows and arrows they practice
traditional forms of fishing and farming
and they carved through rogues as you
can see
uh on the slide out of uh
large trunks of trees that live in
uh that are growing the uh amazon
they have relatively quite little um
interaction with modern society because
they
they are so remote from um from
our way of life uh geographically and
and their uh region of the world is very
inaccessible
uh so they have been largely unaffected
by
all the changes in diet uh uh and and
other factors that have
affected the humans for uh for
hundreds of years now they are also
not subject to the same air pollution
that many
uh individuals in in western countries
uh are uh subjected to and so they live
uh in a a very uh pristine
area of the world and their uh
specific case uh is a very unique one
and so they're they're very much worthy
of our
attention um and investigation
the chimane diet consists
about 17 of protein uh of which about 10
percent
uh consists of game about seven percent
consists of fish they eat
uh mostly lean meat and fish
that come from animals and fish that
live in the
area of the world where they live so
there are peccaries uh tapirs capybaras
uh monkeys uh in that area of
of the forest and uh piranha fish as you
can see catfish
are a big staple of their of their diet
uh they also eat a lot of fruits and
vegetables
that grow in their uh naturally
in their in their region and they
practice
a traditional form of agriculture
they grow some corn um and
a few other vegetables and
and plants that are uh raised that are
grown in a traditional way
now the chimane health and lifestyle
project
is a international consortium
with consisting of
scientists from a wide variety of
disciplines gerontologists like myself
neuroimaging experts anthropologists
uh epidemiologists biologists from
a number of uh universities
in the us in in europe and elsewhere
as well as from south america
and our aim is to study the chimane
people
because we're interested in gaining
insights that can help us to
understand uh the vascular the causes
of vascular disease and neurovascular
and cardiovascular disease
and dementia and i will tell you in this
talk
why the chimane are so interesting from
this particular standpoint
what's shown is in this picture is the
ct scanner that's located
in the city of trinidad bolivia
which is the closest city with an
imaging facility
and that's most proximal to the area of
the world where where the chimane
lives uh there are in and in the past
uh 10 15 years the collaboration has
scanned over
uh 15 to 1800 humane adults
aged uh 40 or over
who have been provided with
transportation from
their villages to the city of trinidad
uh which is a small city of about 30
30 000 people uh located uh
about eight hours drive from
the closest place where the chimane can
be
provided for trans land transportation
and the city has a ct scanning facility
uh where uh the chimney are
can be scanned the boat they receive
both
uh chest ct scans and head
scans the chest scans are used
to quantify coronary artery calcium or
cag
and from head scans we
can quantify brain volume as i will
explain later
we also have extensive clinical and
laboratory data that have been acquired
uh from the chimane there are genetic
data
bio blood biomarkers of inflammation
uh and and other um
quantities that can be extracted from
blood um
and this study has from the its very
inception
uh had the irb approval of all the
institutions in the u.s that are
involved
there's about six or seven of them as
well as
from the bolivian government
and we have local approval from the
chimane
traditional councils from the villages
and from the individuals themselves who
participate in this
collaboration uh and and here you can
see uh uh on the left
this is a picture of myself a few years
ago uh
in the area where the uh chimane lives
uh we uh the group travels there
every year for campaigns to acquire data
from
um from the chimane lately we haven't
been able to do so
because of the pandemic but we
anticipate resuming our work
there after that and here in the middle
you can see the at the bottom you can
see the amazon basin
uh with all its tributaries and the
area shown with the circle is the area
where uh the chimanei live so
they live in the low lands of bolivia a
relatively low altitude
and this is a sample ct scan
chest ct scan from uh the chiman
from sample chimane participant
so in terms of uh lifestyle the
chimane have a lifestyle quite different
from our own as you might expect
their levels of daily exercise
are much higher than in western
societies
so in the u.s the mean number of
average number of steps per day taken by
a u.s individual is
a bit over five or six thousand steps
in uh the chimane culture uh
since they're so involved in fishing
agriculture they're very involved in in
with their environment uh and obtaining
uh
their uh necessities from
the surrounding environment they have um
they're much more physically active so
uh the average
uh chimane female um
registers about 16 000
uh steps per day uh and
they're a little bit uh they walk a
little maybe
uh just a little under the uh number of
a number of steps that the chivane males
take because they're molly more involved
in cooking
taking care of children in the villages
whereas the males
uh walk more because they uh they're
more involved in fishing
and in hunting and so forth and every
family
has to provide for itself uh so
the males of the family often go uh
every day or every other day on on
if they go hunting or fishing and uh
the the females uh are more involved
with
with cooking and taking care of the
children in in the villages
uh and when we look by age category and
uh
as you can see here uh we see that
um there is also a sustained
level of daily physical exercise
throughout the lifespan of the chimanei
so even individuals as you can see here
on the right
who are in their 60s or older than their
60s
still maintain a high level of daily
physical exercise
and this is this is uh possibly quite
significant for
some of the unusual demographics and
epidemiological findings that
that have been reported in the chimane
now there has been quite a bit of study
on how physical activity predicts
mortality and we know that there is a
direct relationship between physical
activity
and decreases in in all-cause mortality
uh this is from a study published almost
10 years ago in the lancet
in a taiwanese population
and we if we look at um on the x-axis we
have
activity levels from inactive to
very active and on the y-axis we have
the hazard ratio
for various causes of mortality
and for all causes we see that there is
a
fairly linear relationship where
physical exercise is protective against
all-cause mortality
it is also protective against cancer
cardiovascular disease and diabetes
so so this has been established uh it's
been known for
a long time and uh as you might expect
uh physical exercise is probably uh
going to affect the the chimanei uh
quite a bit
now uh from the same study there's it's
also been seen
that uh the mortality reduction
associated with exercise with increasing
levels of exercise
uh is dependent on uh the intensity
of physical exercise so the most
vigorous
uh type of exercise leads to
um a greater reduction in
uh mortality with uh um
despite engaging in such exercise
for shorter periods of time so
for example we can achieve about a 45
reduction in all-cause mortality with 50
minutes
of vigorous daily physical exercise
uh but uh with a more moderate
exercise more time more
daily exercises is needed to
achieve comparable levels of mortality
reduction
uh so in terms of dietary intake the
team has
analyzed uh the kind of money
and what has been found is that
their diet differs quite a bit from the
traditional
american diet uh carbohydrates in the us
from about 15 of the american diet
in the chimane they they're about
two-thirds of their diet
uh what's very interesting is that
whereas in the u.s
uh fat intake is about uh
34 total including about
11 saturated fats and two or three
percent
trans fats in the chimanei uh
there's only about 16 fat intake
and only five percent or so um
of the fat intake is associated with
um saturated fats and the amount of
trans fats
that the chiamani consume are is is
is really negligible so there is a
uh basically a big distinction
related to fat intake and uh
respectively and
uh there's about half as much uh of
the percentage of of uh the diet
uh seen in uh the chimane is uh consists
of fat
compared to the united states so 16
versus
34 and the amount of protein intake is
quite comparable
uh now there is something a very
interesting
twist to this story because even though
the chimanei
walk a lot they get in a lot of physical
exercise
they seem to be eating a healthier diet
than the
average american they also have very
high levels
of chronic inflammation because they do
not have access to traditional
um to modern medicine
so there is there also there's a high uh
prevalence of respiratory
inflammatory diseases uh tuberculosis
chronic respiratory infections uh the
chemo
the average humane has about uh four to
six
uh intestinal parasite infections
so there's uh throughout their lives
they experience
a very high systemic inflammatory load
and inflammation is known to be
associated with cardiovascular disease
risk
and here are several uh two comparisons
that are
very illuminating so looking at a c
reactive protein which
as some of you may know is a biomarker
of inflammation
in the chicken a we see that there is
as a function of age there are quite
high levels of crp
in the blood in circulating crp whereas
in the united states
levels are quite a bit lower
significantly lower
similarly if we look at interleukin 6
another biomarker of inflammation we see
substantial differences significant
differences between
the chimanei who have very high levels
of il-6
measured in picograms per milliliter so
this is in the blood
uh compared to the united states where
levels are a lot lower
so so this is interesting because
despite
the benefits uh to the humane lifestyle
that
i already highlighted there is also this
uh twist in the story related to
inflammation and the inflammatory
biomarkers then
the chronic inflammation that the
chiamani exhibit
would lead us to posit that there should
be detrimental effects on health
and this is uh one of the uh key
reasons that humanity are so interesting
to
to study if we look at
blood pressure and cholesterol in the
chimane
we see a different story so
the average systolic blood pressure
is lower on average in the chimanes so
the lower
uh trace uh here on the bottom
compared to the united states at all
ages
and the difference increases uh uh with
age as well
so the largest differences are seen in
those uh
over 60 and
the levels of cholesterol of the
chimanei
uh are significantly significantly lower
than in the united states where uh
which are where the line above uh
plots the the average uh levels by age
so
on the one hand they have very good uh
systolic blood pressure
good cholesterol levels but
on the other hand they have very high
implant inflammation
so the question is how does all that
play out in terms of their
um cardiovascular and brain health
so uh in addition to that
they do not smoke or there is minimal
tobacco smoking
and together all these factors seem to
lead
to some very good lifestyle biomarkers
uh the low density liquid protein so the
bad cholesterol uh lifetime
measure is about 70 milligrams per
deciliter which is
quite good on average the blood pressure
their blood pressure is about 116
or 73 millimeters
mercury and so so these are pretty good
figures
their fasting blood sugar is quite good
and their average bmi
is uh is uh quite reasonable and so
these um factors we have posited
uh may lead to minimal uh coronary
artery calcium throughout life
which has been quantified from the ct
scans that were acquired in
bolivia and
this is uh only one part of the story
uh the other one is that
although they have high infectious loads
high inflammation parasite infections as
i said
and despite having a very much shortened
lifespan so about 54 years
at birth partly or mostly due to these
chronic high inflammatory uh state
uh related disorders that make uh often
causes their death
so they have lower life expectation they
also have
delayed atherosclerosis progression
so this is the cat score by age
on top is what we have in the united
states
so the the x-axis is age
the y-axis is the population percentile
and the z-axis is the cat score and we
see that in
in the united states uh shown here above
we have quite a bit
of check even by by age
55 and
the levels of cac increase dramatically
as a function of population percentile
whereas in the chimane shown here at the
bottom they have
very little coronary artery calcium
throughout their lives and there's only
just minute increases
with age and uh and cac is a
um correlate of atherosclerosis
progression
so uh one what this reflects is that the
chimanei have
very little heart disease they have a
very low incidence of
cardiac infarctions they have low hyper
low prevalence of hyperlipidemia
hypertension
very few cases of heart disease as i
said very few cases of stroke
relatively speaking and
possibly this is due to
their levels of physical activity and
diet but very interestingly despite the
very low
very high inflammation that they have
they have very low
incidence of dementia and um
there was a paper published by our
collaboration in 2017 in the lancet
uh where it was reported that the
chimane exhibit the lowest levels
of coronary atherosclerosis ever
recorded
or known to science in any human
population
and um what this study in the chimane
demonstrated was that
uh even preclinical coronary artery
disease
can be avoided in most people by
achieving
low bad cholesterol
a healthy blood pressure low glucose
in the healthy range a healthy bmi
very little tobacco use and a
considerable amount of daily physical
activity
despite again the presence of very high
levels
of chronic inflammation related to
respiratory tract infections
and what this study by kaplan at al
in the lancet um uh posited
is that in comparison to existing
evidence
the chimane of south america have the
lowest prevalence of coronary
atherosclerosis
despite the high infectious inflammatory
burdens and
and this is very important for what i
will
show you next uh so based on this data
we hypothesize
several things on how brain atrophy
might be related to the levels of
inflammation in the chumane
so we know that brain atrophy rates are
associated with vascular disease
with high cholesterol diabetes
hypertension
all of which are very widespread in
modern industrialized countries
and we know that low cardiovascular risk
is associated with slower brain atrophy
we also know that systemic inflammation
involving the biomarkers i already
described
predicts greater brain activity so in
the chimane we have
they have low cvd risk
so we might predict slower brain atrophy
but because of the high inflammation
systemically we might predict greater
brain atrophy
so the first hypothesis we formulated
was
that the populations with lower
prevalence of cbd
risk factors should exhibit
slower brain atrophy and lower risk of
associated cognitive decline and
dementia
but based on the inflammatory biomarkers
we hypothesize
something that predicts the opposite
namely that high
inflammatory load should lead to faster
brain atrophy
so let's see how that played out so to
test that hypothesis we had to
develop a uh set of algorithms for
for segmenting uh the brain and its
uh components from computed tomography
because
mri is not available in that part of the
world
it's already very difficult to
get ct scans from these participants
uh it would be uh very logistically
challenging to get mri scans from the
chimane
because the the closest uh um uh
city to them only has a ct scanner
so my group has had to develop a uh
segmentation algorithm to um
quantify uh brain volume from ct
so although mri is is uh
more suitable than ct for for brain
mapping uh
especially for uh quantitative
brain morphology there has been growing
ct use throughout the world especially
in the developed world
and for that reason there's been renewed
interest in head ct
segmentation and ct is also more
suitable
in cases where mri is unavailable like
ours where it's unfeasible
where it's counterindicated for
individuals who
cannot get mri scans due to pacemakers
and so forth
or if it's too costly like in many
cases in the developing world or even in
the developed world
and mri segmentation tools as many of
you known
are already technically mature but
there's been very little work
on ct brain segmentation and this is the
one gap
in the technical literature that we have
aimed to fill and
mri methods as we have demonstrated are
actually quite amenable to adaptation to
uh to ct so we have developed a ct-based
brain tissue classification
algorithm where we segment the
outer layers so the scalp
the cranium which is very nicely
segmented from ct as you might expect
and then once we get to the soft tissue
we have developed a way to
separate the gray matter from the white
matter from the css
from ct scans here is an example for one
subject
and here's the you can see the
ventricular system
which uh is actually pretty well
uh delineated you can even see the inter
thalamic adhesion
here a little bit uh you can see the
lateral ventricles the third ventricle
and this method uses a an atlas based
probabilistic labeling tool uh which is
actually quite
standard in the mri literature and has
been used for a long time
and we assign each voxel in in each ct
scan to one of three classes either gray
matter white matter and css
and we have validated this tool in
subjects in the u.s who received both
mri
nct scans for various clinical purposes
and we took
mri as being the gold standard and
and acquired also cts and
segmented their the the brain from
q1 mri using free surfer software
and then used the ct scans acquired from
the same
subjects to classify white matter gray
matter in csf
to calculate intracranial volume and to
estimate
the relative errors in segmentation
accuracy
uh taking mri as the gold standard and
this was published last year
in frontiers in neuroinformatics and
what we found
is that uh using the dice coefficient
which is a very common
metric for this kind of comparisons but
also the
the house dwarf distance which is a more
sophisticated
uh metric we found that the volume
estimation errors
uh for white matter in gray matter uh
were are actually quite reasonable so
we were able to calibrate our
segmentation
method based on mri to achieve zero
percent
average estimation error for both gray
matter
white matter and csf with a standard dev
uh
with an error range of about five
percent so that's two
two standard deviations uh above and
below the mean error
uh five percent for white matter four
percent for gray matter
and about three percent for csf and you
can see here the comparison
between the segmented brain and csf
ventricular system uh in mri versus cct
uh mri as you can imagine has a better
ability to resolve the gyro structure
but ct isn't too bad at all in terms of
finding the total brain volume which is
what we were interested in
and it also does a pretty good job of of
identifying the ventricular system
so we quantified this uh extensively we
didn't find any bias in
volume estimation errors for any of
these measures that we
used uh they all had an approximately
normal distribution
um and this was also the case for both
dice coefficients and house storage
distances uh and to compare
the chimanei to
westerners we undertook a meta-analysis
of 20 years worth of mri literature
summarizing data over almost 10 000
typically aging adults this paper was
recently published online in
neuroinformatics
and we mapped the trajectories of
brain volume gray matter white matter in
css
in uh this meta-analytic sample
meta-analyzed sample from um
from the us and europe as well as
japan and a few other places all all of
these being
industrialized populations and we traced
the
trajectories of these brain measures as
a function of age
after normalization by intracranial
volume to remove that compound
so based on those results we
compared the chimanei rates of
cross-sectional decrease
in brain volume uh
with those observed in the u.s and other
industrialized countries
and what we found is that after
controlling for sex
uh there is a cross-sectional decrease
in brain volume
of about 2.2 per decade in the chimane
compared to about 6.5 percent
per decade in the u.s and so this is
several times
a lower uh rate of atrocity in the
chimane than in the united states
suggesting that the rate of brain aging
and potentially the rate uh the risk for
cognitive impairment
and dementia are modulated to a
substantial extent
by cardiovascular disease incidents
because
the chimanei again have very low
cardiovascular disease
so what are the uh conclusions and
significance
of this well first of all
the chimanei lose brain volume quite
modestly with age
which is consistent with a low burden of
cardiovascular disease
and because cardiovascular health is
associated with brain atrophy it is very
possible that this low risk of
cardiovascular burden
which is uh potentially mediated by
high levels of exercise by a diet
low in trans fats and saturated fats
may have a highly protective effect upon
brain health and
very importantly this suggests that the
brain atrophy
can be reduced substantially by
lifestyles
associated with such low cardiovascular
disease risk
even in the presence of very high
inflammation
and what's very important about this
particular study in the chimae
is that it is it provides unique
evidence
in humans that the effects of
systemic inflammation that's very high
can be counteracted by
healthy diet and exercise and that is
the key
uh reason that the chimanei from the
perspective of
of brain health are such a unique um
and very important population because
normally
in the western societies we have
we might have high level high
percentages of
[Music]
sedentary lifestyle we have air
pollution
but also because of modern medicine we
also have
relatively lower inflammation than in
the chimane
but the chimanei have very high
inflammation
uh while having high levels of
physical activity and a healthier diet
so this is a very unique
environment a very unique setting to
test this hypothesis of
whether exercise and diet can have
a protective effect on brain health
even in the presence of systemic
inflammation which is
uh which is a problem uh not only the
chimane but also in western societies as
well
so this also has implications for
prevention
it suggests that a diet of a very lean
wild game and fish
is probably beneficial for health for
brain health and
cardiovascular health and it's probably
it indicates that among the chumane
one can avoid coronary atherosclerosis
by by
doing a lot of exercise and consuming
very low doses of saturated
and trans fats and
a key quote from the original
publication is that
urbanization and the elimination of a
subsistence diet
and lifestyle as uh
seen in modern societies might represent
a novel risk factors for coronary artery
disease
so in conclusion it's very possible
that at least some of the
increases in coronary artery disease
in diabetes in
dementia cognitive impairment that we
see
today in our societies are possibly due
to the fact that we live in this
industrialized highly urbanized
environment
with pollution where we where many
people
live a sedentary lifestyle and uh
have unhealthy diets so
in conclusion i would like to thank
everyone who has been part of this this
is a
huge collaboration spanning several
uh lots of institutions many countries
uh it's a very interdisciplinary team
i'd like to thank everyone
at usc who is part of this
as well as at all the other uh locations
in bolivia in the united states in
europe and elsewhere
um i'd like to thank my mentor tak tak
finch here in
usc in gerontology and margie gatz who
have
uh with whom i've been collaborating
on this project for the past five years
and uh thank you very much for your
interest and attention
uh thank you jack for inviting me and
thank you i'd like to thank the
organizers and the nih
for organizing this series um
and this uh innovation lab i'd like to
thank the chumane health and lifestyle
project team
and the national institutes of health
particularly the national institute on
aging
which has funded this
work under an rf1 grant
and here at the bottom uh
is a picture of me in uh
during our last trip to bolivia and here
standing next to me is the
the president of the chumanai so this is
i have to say the the first president
that i've
that i've ever met so uh this picture
was a
very nice uh and uh uh unique
opportunity for me so uh thank you very
much
uh for your attention and uh i would
love to
hear any questions you might have uh
andre that was a fantastic
talk thank you so much for for sharing
that with us really intriguing
uh kind of journey that you took as well
as
hearing about the um the the issues that
present themselves to the
german a people and just but how their
lifestyle
seems to kind of uh be protective for
brain health
i like the picture at the end because
you're literally rubbing
elbows with world leaders in order to
conduct this this study is
pretty good um one of the the a couple
of questions which are kind of rolled in
but it was also a question i had
about this as well is that physical
exercise in particular has been um
associated with all manner of protective
uh brain health or as protective for
brain health and this can
i'm aware of studies in parkinson's
disease huntington's disease multiple
sclerosis alzheimer's disease
and all as well as just general
psychiatric health
and i'm uh curious if the chumani people
show reduced rates of these
diseases disorders and dysfunctions as
well
and if you can comment on them yes
uh so they show extremely low
rates of uh cognitive impairment very
very low rates of dementia
uh several many in fact
more than i think more than an order of
magnitude lower than
in the united states uh also much
lower rates of diabetes um
as far as parkinson's disease so we are
we have the team has been
acquiring cognitive assessments of uh of
the
chimane and that data is still under
analysis so so we haven't
distinguished between dementia in
general and alzheimer's in particular
partly because we don't have pet
available but
there's very lit very few very low rate
of parkinsonism
and uh it seems that even the cases that
just based on preliminary data even the
the
cases of dementia that do occur seem to
have a
a rather a unique presentation which is
uh somewhat different from from the
presentation of dementia
in industrialized nations and as far as
the
mental health uh i think
uh i have to say i i'm not completely
sure i think that
but i do believe that the profile and
prevalence are also
uh quite different from western society
interesting um one thing i was curious
about as you were talking about the the
just the level of participation and i
realize there's some
you know logistical challenges of
getting um
your your subjects to um to the to where
the scanner is located and what not
um what do the what did the chumane get
out of it
right so they're participating in this
dude what's the benefit to them
uh what motivates them to want to
participate in studies like this
yes uh the team has been
very involved with the chumane for 20
years
the team has developed a very
good working relationship with them
they every time they come over to
trinidad
for the scans for these research scans
they also get physical exams
and treatment for whatever
medical conditions they might have they
also
receive some supplies
that is useful to them in their
day-to-day life
so they they do
[Music]
have some artisanal um
well they so there's some uh they knit
they sew so there's various forms of uh
uh waves that we that the team can
assist the the chumane
while preserving their way of life so
this so there's uh
uh supplies like that that are provided
so there's various ways like that but
the i think the the primary
incentive is um is the fact that they
they receive medical uh attention and
and treatment uh um and follow-up
as a result of this project right and
are you getting full genome sequences
with uh these um with the tumor name
as well there is um
i know that so i'm not the genome data
we're just
starting to look at in more detail and
uh
we are getting i think i think it is
uh full genome sequencing uh if uh
and uh there is definitely uh
genotyping get a very large number of
snips uh if if
if full genome sequencing is not done
and do do the journey suffer from any
particular prevalence of
genetic disorders uh
that does not seem to be the case but
again we have not
analyzed the genetic data in very much
detail yet one interesting uh
potential finding that's very
preliminary is that
sequencing has confirmed that they are
quite
genetically distant from so there's been
very little
admixture between them and surrounding
indigenous populations um
and there's there's also been little uh
genetic
admixture with the uh that is of
uh with individuals of european descent
so there's all
so there's less than less than ten
percent
or maybe five or even less are uh have
any
uh genetic contributions from
um from uh from
previous uh interaction with european
europeans or persons with
of european descent fantastic
um what about uh
are are there any implications from what
you're learning about from the germany
that can directly affect us here in the
u.s
and in you know kind of more modern
societies around the world that
you know you kind of mentioned healthy
eating and whatnot
um on the other hand i've probably been
not eating healthy for
oh 50 years or so is it too late for me
unlike the two money who presumably
spend their lifetime doing it
um and get to get the benefits of it is
it is it something that one can
arrest any downward slide
into dementia uh yeah so definitely
even interventions at a later age can be
beneficial
uh for example and this is not based on
data that i have shown but uh
there's there's a lot of interest now in
epigenetic clocks for example
in uh methylation clocks that uh
quantify the extent of dna methylation
and allow us to estimate biological age
of tissues of individuals based on
the extent of dna methylation and
and what what some of those studies have
shown is that
changes in in lifestyle
can lead to a lower rate of dna
methylation
which translates into a slowing down of
the aging process in various uh
various tissues and and cell cell type
lineages
um so so that's but that's
coming from outside this particular work
uh
from the chimanei uh what we do know is
that
what we have found is that
despite the fact that in the united
states and in other western societies we
have
very high rates of inflammation
chronic inflammation especially at the
older ages
uh because of diet or
air pollution or sedentary lifestyle
um even and even causes of
other inflammation that so that cannot
necessarily be
removed so for example air pollution uh
for many people is not a factor that can
be
easily addressed the
the changes in the diet and changes in
in diet in exercise
can tremendously assist with creating
a protective effect against the inf
pro-inflammatory uh factors
that are damaging to health and i think
that's the
one of the key uh reasons that the
chimane
are so interesting to study is because
this is a very unique population
where on the one hand you have high
exercise
uh very relatively healthier diet
but on the other hand also very high
inflammatory loads
and yet the brain atrophy and the brain
shrinking profiles as a function of age
are very much slower than in
in the united states so that seems to
indicate
that there is some major protective
effect associated with exercise
and diet and to the extent that these
relationships are causal in the chimanei
uh that can also uh uh
prevent and and lower the rates of
cognitive decline and dementia
what are the next studies that one hopes
to do
with uh the chi monet and uh that can
help
kind of answer some of the outstanding
questions that you have left
uh so for the moment the uh the start
of our campaigns are have been paused
because of the pandemic
interestingly enough although the
the covet virus has reached bolivia and
and trinidad and the chimane villages
uh uh very very there have been
very very few deaths among the chimanei
from
the covid virus which is again very
surprising because they have a very high
inflammatory load uh which should
translate into a high risk
but they seem uh and this is something
we're we're studying now
we only have uh some epidemiological
data that's very preliminary at the
moment
but it's going to be very interesting to
look at
why um the uh
the percentage of of covid's
survivors uh is so high
relative to the rates of infection and
also why
the most of the symptoms in those who do
get covid
are so much milder than than
in countries like our own and in europe
so that's something that we have
received funding from the nih to study
soon as soon as we can resume our
campaigns we also
plan to rescan the chimane
their brains to turn this into a
longitudinal study rather than a
cross-sectional study
so we're interested now in in
quantifying
um brain aging in a
longitudinal design and looking at all
the other
inflammatory factors and and other
variables of interest in the
longitudinal um
settings so that's going to be a major
effort going forward
and and possibly uh we could even look
at uh
some methylation clocks and uh uh and
look at the
changes in the rate of a of biological
aging and
and so um that i imagine that's gonna
keep us quite busy for the next
five or five to ten well
it's a fascinating study it's a really
fantastic opportunity to understand how
brain aging affects this
unique population and kind of the
implications that that
and their lifestyle has for our own um
fantastic talk thank you so much dr
erimia for sharing that with us
um with that i think we're kind of at
our time i want to thank dr ira mia from
the university of southern california
for sharing his work with us
i want to thank uh all the people who uh
joined us today both on uh our
innovation lab participants on zoom and
everybody out on youtube
um with that thank you very much and
thank you once again dr aramia
thank you for having me